buen trabajo ahora es momento de agregar
un resorte imaginemos que un extremo del
resorte lo conectamos a nuestra
particular y el otro a un punto de
anclaje como se ve aquí la partícula
está siendo jalada hacia abajo por la
gravedad provocando que el resorte se
estire cuando se desplazan los resortes
tratan de contraerse de nuevo y a esto
se le conoce como fuerza del resorte en
la elección 1 vimos como la intensidad
de esta fuerza del resorte depende del
desplazamiento y de la rigidez del
resorte y podemos expresar la rigidez de
un resorte con una variable k llamada la
constante del resorte a esto se le
conoce como la ley de hook la fuerza del
resorte es igual a menos que
multiplicada por el desplazamiento ahora
vamos a modificar nuestro programa para
incluir este nuevo resorte primero voy a
agregar nuestras variables en los
ajustes iniciales para la posición del
anclaje del resorte una para la
coordenada x y otra para la coordenada
jeff a estas las voy a llamar encore ex
y en uruguay o anclaje x y anclaje y en
inglés voy a establecer sus valores de
modo que el anclaje
en el centro de la pantalla hay otro
ajuste inicial que debemos considerar
que es la constante del resorte esta
expresa qué tan rígido es el resorte
vamos a llamarla acá ya darle un valor
de digamos 7 ahora podemos ir a nuestra
función de dibujo draw y agregar la
fuerza del resorte voy a definir una
nueva variable que se llame sprints
force guay fuerza resorte y en inglés
para representar las fuerzas verticales
del resorte a partir de la ley de hook
sabemos que esta fuerza del resorte
nieme springs force white será igual a
menos que multiplicada por el
desplazamiento o bien a position why
menos en uruguay que es la distancia del
anclaje a la masa ahora sólo tenemos que
agregar nuestra fuerza del resorte al
cálculo existente de la fuerza en ye lo
cual nos da force white es igual a
spring force why más la masa por la
gravedad y eso es todo para actualizar
nuestras fuerzas por último sólo
necesitamos dibujar unas cosas para
tomar en cuenta el resorte que acabamos
de agregar voy a dibujar un anclaje con
una cajita centrada en la posición del
anclaje que
en nuestros ajustes iniciales y voy a
dibujar el resorte con una línea que se
extienda del anclaje hasta la posición
de la partícula así ahora vamos a
ejecutar nuestra simulación y ver qué
pasa
está vivo vamos a pausar aquí para que
te sientas cómodo con este sistema masa
resorte